the classical way of going through this
topic is to say okay here's this am very
very abstract skill which i'm going to
teach it's completely algebraic it seems
completely divorced from reality and
it's very very armed I like everything
is variables and prim minerals etc and
then later on like weeks later you
discover it has this really cool
application right after I have to do
with probability mainly in our context
okay so I'm going to kind of turn that
upside down a little bit because I think
it's kind of cool to the way you're
going and why order this principle is
useful its method is useful because
rather than saying hey you know you'll
find out later there's no reason why you
can't find out now okay as opposed to as
I explained yesterday um this thing it's
like well you know actually there's a
really good reason we don't tell you
that from the get go where we want you
to know the area of circle because
there's lots of things you need to know
I huge numbers of things you need to
know in order to be able to get for the
left hand side to the right hand side
but what we need to understand why this
is useful you can understand right now
so what is this thing what kind of
diagram is this for this is what I a
tree diagram right I'm about to make it
a probability tree diagram by labeling
each of the branches because what we're
looking at here is the probability of
some sort of event right and then does
anyone remember what that squiggly line
means I yes so there's a variety of
words that I use for this the most
common one is compliments so in the
context of probability what that means
is you know it's either you know you
roll a 6 when you roll the die or you
roll some other number that's not a six
and those are the only options six not
six okay or Sonny not so as opposed to
say for instance sunny and raining are
not compliments right like they tend not
to happen together but they can and
there are also other things that are
neither Sun nor rain like say overcast
right so what we mean here are the the
complement of e so these are opposite
events now let's actually go with the
six not six I did just as an example
okay if I said this arm what II was
these are wrong
six roller 6 on standard fare okay and
so this is roll one two three four or
five okay what would the probabilities
on my brother's actually be a sixth at
five six yeah good morning i'm going to
put another college a 6156 okay now you
can see in this particular probability
tree diagram what I'm imagining is that
I roll man died and then I roll a die
again right so that's what this second
set of branches is all about okay but
because of the nature of dice like these
are independent events right so you roll
one and then you roll the second one and
then affect each other okay so when I
have a look at the probabilities on
these sets of watches they end up being
exactly the same right they don't change
unlike say all I don't know you know
taking marbles out of a bag and it's
like well once I take them out that
changes you know based on what I pull
that first time what about the second
time will be different okay so these are
the kinds of things that are happening
here now where would we normally go is
say okay well let's work out not stale
bread let's work out what the term
phobia any of these events is and you
multiply along the branches if you want
to work out what happens if you're all
six and then all the six again okay now
for the second illustration shame to
connect us to this concept properly
right I'm not actually going to evaluate
i'm just going to write like what are
these probabilities okay so in the first
case you're pinning and six times a six
and we all know what that is but i'm
just going to write in the song is
actually more helpful why I'm in here
right all six then don't know six the
probability will be a six times five
seats right further map five six times
16 and then lastly this is 56 that's
where okay now if I were then to flip
around the question a little bit and say
okay let's take this list of
probabilities and now what I'm
interested in is what's the probability
two sixes or 16 or 0-60
okay what are each of those going to add
up to this is a fairly simple example so
the numbers will end up simple over here
right there is only one way there's only
one way to get this probability okay of
having two sixes so if I say probability
of 2 i'll write the number sixes okay
there's only a single way to do that and
you're going to get one out of 36 I'm
just going to pause on that one for a
second if I want to have the probability
of just 16 there are actually two ways
to get that right so when I work out
what this number is I have to include
both of these ways does that make sense
and then lastly the probability of
getting 0 sixes this guy here again
there's only a single way of doing this
okay now wonder if you can see how this
connects to our binomial coefficients
okay you've got two sets of things that
are happening right this times this
right so there is a function that's
being squared and then you've got one
way you've got two ways you got one way
other numbers started to become familiar
this is actually to 20 times the 6
squared right does that make sense to 20
there's one way of doing this okay we're
just for here to choose one there's 16
in there so there's one two different
options i'm choosing only one times this
number here you can see I can have it in
either order does that make sense and
then lastly here what we really got is
to choose 2 times 5 6 square okay so if
I were to change these from a six and
five six to be more general and just to
say like let's just call this a and B
right and then what you're getting over
here is the familiar binomial
coefficients that you seen before right
this is going to be 220 a squared this
will be 21 a B and this will be
2b squared right which of course once
you combine all of these things together
gives you the sum of all of the terms in
your binder new expansion like to choose
one of course is just one plus that is
too and this is one okay so you can see
this is where the binomial expansion
cultural I could have done any higher
power i like I just wanted to make the
diagram small enough for you to draw
okay so the idea now here is finding the
greatest coefficient right which one of
these is going to end up the largest
what this is really a mechanism to find
out in our context well what's the most
likely event what is the most likely
event to occur please because it will
correspond to the highest probability
the greatest number okay now in an
example I thought what I chose it's kind
of trivial to work out what that is okay
cuz obviously that's the most common
thing but if I were to change a and B so
they were a little more like closer
together and if I had more events coming
out right so for example suppose I
rolled you know a hundred dice a hundred
dives right and then I was not asking
okay you know is it going to be more
likely that i have 100 sixes or you know
100 not 6s that's really really easy
what if i was it just interested in
numbers two and three there's lots and
lots of different ways to get just the
two and three there's going to be lots
of these guys in the middle that will
add up so which one is the most what's
the most common number of twos and
threes again I don't know it's a non
trivial question it actually takes some
work okay so that's what this kind of
this which I'm going to demonstrate to
you now in or theory in abstract terms
that's where that's where this is going
okay is it trying to solve a probability
problem